why is Donald Trump tweeting such a risk
in 2017 well I mean I made that remark
it's you know somewhat tongue-in-cheek
but we've already seen that trumps
tweets can knock value off of company's
share price change corporate operations
planning and also change what members of
Congress do the reason why I said that
it was among the biggest global
political risks is because if political
risk in the best of times is difficult
to price this is an entirely unfiltered
and a new mechanism all market surprises
and accidents just waiting to happen
Tina how long before what you return an
accident or a surprise really comes to
the fore well in terms of one that moves
markets and we haven't seen that yet
right most of the moves that Trump is
made in his first week in office and the
executive orders which have certainly
rocks public opinion generated huge
protests and everything else haven't
affected what investors and companies
are most focused on from this
administration so you know we haven't
changed our views on expectations of
growth of deregulation and and
everything else but political risk is
defined by where there is a disconnect
between the politics and the economics
and that's very much what we are
observing right now we have a bunch of
CEOs from a particular industry that get
invited to the Oval Office and come out
and make very positive comments and then
we get you know tweets that you know X
company is keeping or creating jobs in
the United States is this how government
is supposed to work well it certainly
isn't how government has typically
worked in the past and furthermore what
we have is clearly a real mix of
developments right some of which are
clearly market-friendly and business
friendly but the overall operating
environment is one that is going to be
characterized quite clearly by
uncertainty and some would argue that
that is in itself is a strategy by the
administration to too
keep people on their toes to keep those
CEOs coming and and wanting to stay in
good stead with this administration
that's not normally how we do things how
do you score for all this when you're
trying to figure out how the economy is
going to fare over the next 12 to 24
months Tina I mean you have these
announcements do they really mean
anything to economic fundamentals at the
end of the day so far they don't I think
what where things really start to get
more complicated is is in the event that
some of these developments are
challenged in court that the president's
executive orders aren't executable that
reforms like for Obamacare and others
take longer than expected and in that
sense markets have gotten ahead of a
political process that just takes time
and then there is the risk as we saw as
Trump took office prediction market
suggested a fifty percent probability he
wouldn't finish his first term and so
investors will also be looking for the
possibility that some of these
developments are are not presidential
Tina how do you think European investors
are pricing political risk how do you
gauge the political risk premium ahead
of the you know the key events to come
this year german french dutch elections
could be more could be italy as well
look what's happening in greece greece
is still to agree on you know the latest
bailout review how do you think risk is
being priced in Europe right now ahead
of these key events well we've said that
Europe is really in the crosshairs of
much of these political risk
developments between Trump and even just
possibility and changes of trade and and
other types of engagements and with
brexit on going through 2017 and Beyond
plus all the European elections that you
mentioned so investors are very aware
that political risks are higher but at
the same time stock market performance
is not much affected and really as ever
all eyes are on the feds so I think
there's not enough information for
investors to change their strategy but
the sense of precariousness
due to more actors and more volatility
is quite apparent